live here
welcome everybody John Perry here
we are doing Live Another live stream
I'm going to be doing this all through
the month of December at the end of
December I will be going to Ecuador so I
won't be doing them there but until the
end of December we'll be doing these and
when I get back from Ecuador in January
we'll start doing them again
it's just I've been I've had some people
complain because they they liked the uh
the more edited videos and then I had
when I stopped doing streams had people
complain that they wanted me to do more
streams uh and
what I'm doing here every time I do a
live stream is I'm going to have a
really obvious red circle the live uh
the live stream icon and the title and
so you'll know if if you're one of the
viewers who would rather watch the
edited videos they will not have that
big red circle on the on the front of
the title and for those of you who like
the live videos they will have the red
circle on the title there so that'll be
the way to easily distinguish
which type of video you're watching when
it comes up in your feed
I today
I am joined by William O
and
William welcome
we are going to be talking today about
science what is science we're going to
be diving into that William is he he
studies ecology at uh at the the
University of British Columbia
and just tell us about yourself and by
the way I apologize for my my lagging
video I'm not totally sure what's going
on with my uh
computer today but
all right so William tell us about
yourself tell us
what you're studying what got you
interested in it
um oh
I guess I'll try to keep it short yeah
um so yeah I'm a PhD student at UBC
um
I'm a community ecologist studying in
maintenance of biodiversity so the
questions that we ask for example are
why are there so many species
why not more why not less and how do
they coexist
um and usually this is frame in terms of
the context of competition which I think
arguably most of the college and
evolution is
um and so this is the idea that there's
something out there or there are niches
that species kind of evolve to fit into
and I'm kind of interested in some sense
like the inverse problem where can
organisms create those niches through
their impact and their environments
um I'm trying to build some computer
simulation theoretical models and also
using some experiments to examine some
of these ideas
um so yeah that's kind of the gist of it
[Music]
um
do I want should I go into how like how
I got how I got here where yeah well
okay so
this is called computational biology
right
this whole field what you're doing so so
you're doing you're trying to use
math to model ecological systems is that
right and the Dynamics of these systems
um in I mean half and half I mean one I
think the math is I think this is the
misinterpretation that people a lot of
people have where the method is just
some some way to for us to formalize our
Concepts and ideas it's kind of yeah at
least how I'm using it it's more of a
proof of concept and then we can like
start looking at what kind of systems
might these work and
um so I guess I'm using like math as
kind of more of a facilitative
um tool rather than something that's
like
more grounded and this is it yeah that
thing
yeah so what got you interested in this
in the first place
um
oh I don't know like this specific
question or this like
I think biology in general because it's
so hard for me because like I'm just I
have like a very broad set of interests
yeah
um
but I guess what got me interested in
this particular question is
um a little bit more on like the
philosophical aspect of biology that I
like something that's like always been
interested interesting to me
um
I mean yeah biology is something so
as a scientist so
close to us right it's like yeah we are
also living and then when you're
studying living things you're like well
like what does that say about me right
right so I'm kind of interested in kind
of exploring some of these ideas and
like how do we make sense of ourselves
and then like
um
is our notion of who we are also
kind of influencing the kind of
questions we ask and what kind of what
kind of things we're looking for and how
do we frame our theories and Concepts
yeah
um yeah so that's kind of the more big
picture
um
thing that got me interested in this and
of course like I think and like with any
biologists and
oh
that's fine
um but yeah I feel like also with just
any biologist like you know I'm just
fascinated by the diversity of life
forms on Earth and
yeah
yeah
so so it's been for you it's been a lot
of um like what does this mean for us
humans like when we're when we're
studying ecology when we're studying
evolution
however what does it say about us
uh uh I think in the back of my head a
little bit for sure yeah
like so you and I met on Twitter and it
was uh the last conversation I remember
having with you it was about the
the concept of agency so uh you were
asking if
uh you know biologists tend to frown on
the idea that uh that organisms have
agency and yeah phobia basically yeah
um and you were asking why that is
you're asking if it's if it's a cultural
thing and uh my my response was that
that that just that word agency has a
lot of baggage in Western culture all
right like we
so it is a cultural thing yeah oh yeah
yeah I mean I was raised in a super
religious background and the
like we talked about free agency all the
time
and it was this sort of like mystical uh
thing where uh we are fully free to
um
you know determine our future and and so
on
and I think
yeah it has this sort of a mystical sort
of uh uh spiritual aspect to it
within Christianity
and I think that that's probably one of
the reasons that a lot of biologists shy
away from it because it just has all
this all sorts of meaning behind it but
for sure an organism that can respond to
stimuli
it you could consider that thing to be
an agent right it's it's reacting to
things around it
but you know there's if we're going to
be making up terms we would you know
try to make up a term that doesn't
already have a bunch of baggage I
suppose
but
uh
this got us onto the topic of of what is
science in general and and why are some
some things allowed to be talked about
in science some things that are not
allowed to or just we tend to be uh we
tend to have this phobia of using
certain types of words to describe
things in biology and so on so I thought
it'd be fun for us to do a video where
we both uh we both present what our
pictures are of science
uh
and then we see how different they are
but I think maybe even before we do that
where did you grow up and do you think
that influenced your view of science at
all
yeah that's a great question
um it's just so I think this is a really
important point to make except because
um so growing up I grew up in the
Philippines and I went to a Christian
School actually
um for like 13 years and
I grew up thinking I was like you know
believing God and like was kind of a
pretty devoted Christian in some sense
um and so much so that like I actually
thought my parents were gonna go to hell
because they they weren't Christian yeah
and then yeah and so that was definitely
like one of my biggest
um kind of identity first first first
like identity label I guess
um
but then like I uh learned science
um I fell in love with it just because
of how how objective it is and like how
Universal that like you know I'm a
single individual and a human being but
for some reason I share
I share the same rules that like apply
to me to you know you and maybe there's
some rules I apply to this chair that
also apply to me some sense and I'm just
like wow this is so cool
um
and then of course like I said like and
then I was like okay well let's look at
biology which is like literally what I
am and the science of that
um and then I kind of got into genetics
because I thought that I was like oh
it's so like so rigid and like
we can explain everything from my own
behavior other people's behavior society
and stuff like that
um and just like yeah it's so much
certainty there
um and this is really funny because
anyone who knows me now will know that
this is so strange because I'm like
super hating on some of these views now
which is the idea of biological
determinism yeah um but but but the
point to make is that
um I was kind of a hardcore materialist
and determinist and now as a as a like a
as a researcher and the more and more
read about some of this stuff I'm just
like
I'm not sure if like
yeah when you go into detail about
things and things look a bit hand wavy
and then so you just like you know start
questioning whether the things you
learned in school was actually like
just obviously it's obviously always a
simplification right but then people
take those certifications as truth and
objective and so
um
yeah and so now I've been reflecting
more about like how do we deal with this
and is it good or is it bad how do we
deal with uncertainty in science
yeah yeah or like how do we tackle
communicating science in public and also
children yeah this this is something
that uh that I've I've also been really
concerned with like how do we deal with
this was so obvious with kovid but like
how do we communicate the uncertainty
that exists in science
even like you know because I I create
teaching materials for classrooms and I
definitely don't want to
like give a false impression that
everything that we understand is Rock
Solid of course there's lots of uh
there's a there's there's lots of gaps
in our understanding and I want to be
able to communicate that and I I mean
it's been a big part of my priority from
the start with stated clearly I don't
know how many animations you watched but
or which ones did you watch do you
remember which ones you'd seen
um I think I saw the random mutations
that oh animations I think there's a
origin of Life One or something yeah
right yeah yeah there's several of those
so in in in those ones my I was working
with the center for chemical Evolution
and one of our big goals was to make it
very clear to the audience that the
problem's not solved because uh we did a
couple of presentations early on with
the public and we had people raise their
hand if they if they thought this was
already solved and figured out and a
bunch of people thought that the origin
of life was already solved and this made
uh like uh Nick HUD who's the director
of the center he was frustrated with
this because he would get students and
that would think that as well and he's
like no I'm trying to recruit people
that can help us figure this out
so there's there has been this big
problem in science communication where
we have somehow oversold what we know
and don't know or you know and and so
what we try to do with those videos
would be very very clear about what's
understood and what's not understood
what are the problems that we're trying
to work on and and so on so I don't know
what your impression was of that video
but hopefully uh hopefully you felt that
we were being transparent there with
with all that stuff
um
so
okay so so you were raised in the you
grew up in the Philippines
Christian background did you did you
leave your religion when you
became when you got really into science
oh yeah for sure yeah I was like just
became hardcore atheist yeah we don't
need these just explanations to explain
the empirical world yeah
um where where are you right now with
that I mean oh oh
um
I'm kind of leaning towards I'm kind of
I I guess I consider myself more of an
agnostic now yeah
and I think this is related to the
uncertainty aspect where like
I'm just a skeptic and so it's really
hard to say that there's not nothing and
like I guess also maybe my my definition
of God is a little bit
I'm more open to different definitions
of what God is it's definitely not a guy
with a white beard
um yeah but it could be some kind of
natural force or
maybe a group of things entities or yeah
yeah
all right
so how would you define science
um okay let's see I have this written
down this is a such an important thing
to not not screw up yeah but
um
so I think the science is science is the
process of generating explanations of
empirical observations
through the reciprocal feedback between
Theory and experimentation
nice
and just to add on to that so explain I
think explanations are generated via
kind of this process of consensus
consensus building which makes science a
social Enterprise subjected biases
values and historical contentions
so ideally we should remove these things
but I don't I'm not sure if it's
possible and if it's not possible I
think we should definitely be critical
and confront them so explain that again
so that the contingent it's contingent
on
like his history context yeah historical
context and so what did it what did an
idea come about in history where in
space geographically and who said it how
did they say it kind of what what were
even their their politics at the time
yeah so my definition of science pretty
similar to yours I I describe it as a
the collection and documentation of
observations and an ongoing argument
argument about what those observations
might mean
and uh I say argument because uh things
can things get really intense in science
which is fun yeah uh yeah
but you know that the foundation of
science is this uh these observations
and uh the one of the
big things that I think sets apart the
scientific
movement I guess
you know when trying to study the
history of science it's very uh like
you just learn about people in Europe
basically when you're studying Science
History
um which is a shame like I really wish I
I wish that we spent more time studying
things like Alchemy and especially
studying things that like because
obviously if you look at different
cultures around the world when when we
say that science was you know coming
into being which is what Galileo's time
is kind of when we think of modern
science coming coming about but
there was there were huge civilizations
that obviously had something akin to
science otherwise they wouldn't be have
these giant amazing structures that and
societies that they're
that they're uh they're living in
but the
the big shift that happened at least in
in Western thought at that time was
uh take no one's word for it there's
this this slogan nolius and verba which
is from the it's I think it's the the
Royal Society the scientific society's
slogan which means take no one's word
for it and that you know talking about
historical context
I'm not a historian but I would say that
that comes from a it comes a lot from
the uh like the the Rebellion against
the Catholic Church
you had the all the Protestants that
were trying to interpret their religion
from the Bible like observations that
they're making in the text of the Bible
and then comparing that to what the pope
was saying
and so you had this big revolution
within Christianity at the time
and it seems like that way of thinking
bled over into
observations in nature and so like that
we have this very strict form of
argument that happened within
Christianity that bled over into science
and then you have instead of instead of
focusing on what you were seeing in the
Bible they were focusing on what we're
seeing in nature and that is the uh
like observation is the doctrine that
everything else is based on so it's it's
the foundation of Science and they
became extremely extremely strict about
that and that's I think what really
separates
the thing that we call Western science
from
things that were happening before then
it's just like observation is the King
here
when you say observation do you mean
like induction
yeah well things that things that you
take in with your senses that you can
show someone else and they would agree
that yeah that's so like I can show you
at what temperature water boils at and I
can show you that it's different high up
on a mountain versus at sea level
I can show you these things you can see
them I can show you a fossil you might
not we might not agree on what it is but
I can show it to you and I can I can
point out all the observations that I'm
making with it we can feel it we can you
can lick the thing you can like you can
use your senses and then we can argue
about what what on Earth that means like
what does what does this skeleton Frozen
and rock mean
and uh
you just have this this yeah this
collection of observations more and more
observations they build up and then you
end up coming up with a conclusion or
with with some sort of a description to
tie all those things together and that
description
um
like the way that we interpret
everything is very much
influenced by our culture it's very much
influenced by
um
different Power structures within that
society which is why it's so important
now I I it was important from the start
that the more people from more cultures
that we have that are doing this I think
that
the more the more true or the more
accurate our conclusions end up being
because we have
yeah we have people fighting back and
pushing back on things and
um it's
it's been
uh
I feel like it's very important to reach
out to larger audiences which is why I
do science Outreach because we want more
we want more people from more
backgrounds
joining in on this argument
so
um I kind of want to just want to
um say that
um
I'm not sure if it's
observation alone that's kind of the
basis of science so I feel like
um one thing that I've read between my
definition and your definition is
um the emphasis on the feedback between
Theory or I say concept development and
observations
yeah I don't know if you're familiar
with the idea of uh theory-relatedness
of observations no all right sorry again
theory-relatedness theory-relatedness oh
yeah oh yes yes yes yes yeah yeah so
um this is really funny because I'm I'm
kind of like empiricist but do a little
bit of theory and I kind of think about
these two things simultaneously yeah and
it's so funny because like I actually
just give a talk recently about this
um theoreticians you know they look at
empiricists and they're like oh this is
just data it's just Just So Stories
whatever
um it's not rigorous it's not
mathematical and then like the
impressive will say oh it's just Theory
it's not real
um but like I think
it's it's
um almost impossible to do any sort of
observations without any theories
um because what what we choose to
observe what we think is relevant still
comes with some sort of theoretical
Foundation
um so for example I'm like counting ants
right and so like I have to have a
concept of what an ant is and like what
constitutes an individual
um and so and and obviously that's going
to reflect on your data and your
observation yeah and so it's really I
think
um really important to
acknowledge the theory or framework that
you're using so then that you can
basically falsify it defeat it if things
go unexpected
yeah yeah so well I've used this analogy
when I'm teaching about what you know
what is science before where like
imagine you wake up in a castle
and
there's just puzzle pieces up to your
waist there's a giant castle you don't
know how big the castle is you don't
know if these puzzle pieces make a
picture or not but you just start
walking around and you start finding you
you end up finding pieces that seem like
they fit together and we'll just imagine
that this puzzle is cut in a way that
it's just a jigsaw puzzle but it's cut
in a way that any piece could be linked
to any other piece
but you start finding pieces that of the
the kind of the same color I think maybe
there's actually a picture here you
start putting together a picture and
other people are doing the same thing
and they're coming up with different
pictures
the general idea that everyone has is
that there is a picture here
uh and people are going to start putting
together those pictures and as they
start doing that
as a picture starts to form
that's going to tell you where what
puzzle pieces you're missing and it's
going to help you figure out what you
should look at and so this is like if
you if you if you consider these puzzle
pieces the observations and then the
linking of the puzzle pieces as Theory
building
the theory tells you what you should go
out and look for so that's I guess the
theory lateness of observation
um yeah that's gonna direct me and I
might
my picture might be totally wrong and so
I'm not I'm ignoring pieces that would
fit in it right
uh and I'm looking for pieces that just
aren't they shouldn't they have nothing
to do with what's real
so you can definitely get stuck in a
trap and we we saw this with um
you know with the black plague for
example they're all the different
theories that people went through with
the black plague like
some people thought that it was the
asteroid or it was like a you know it's
like stars that were bringing the Black
Plague
uh some people thought that it was bad
smells some people thought that it was
certain groups of people that were doing
it so they executed thousands of Jews
during the black plague were executed
because the they were blamed for
poisoning the well and so on
so these are all bad theories and people
were building this picture based on
observations that they're making just
the wrong observations and we can do
this for a long time uh in science we
can do this you know
politically and so on so yeah it it is a
problem but but what we see is that what
we see is that uh
these pictures that are built these
theories that are built they get
replaced by better ones
like
the the picture that's leading to more
discoveries because these these you know
these theories help us create hypotheses
and the hypotheses tell us where to go
look for new observations
and if when you have a good theory it's
going to be consistently leading you to
new observations that fit and help you
build that that uh
picture more more effectively more
efficiently so there how do you feel the
um
do you feel like we're
do you feel like there's a there's a
solid progress in science or do you feel
that yeah what is your current feeling
in your own field of research like are
we spinning our tires or are we making
progress
uh
uh I think we're definitely moving
forward that's not yeah for sure but the
question is more of
can we move faster and better and more
justly
um like the question that I'm kind of
really interested in myself is
um you know dude do theories and
Concepts Frameworks necessarily have to
replace each other
um yeah like
and
like it's not like a process of
elimination kind of thing right
um so I'm a little bit of a pluralist
and this is a little bit kind of like my
my view about agency as well it's I'm
not sure if it's like ontologically real
and true but if this framing of the
question of living things
um can
it might it might have the same
explanatory like power
um as opposed to like you know without
the idea of agency but what if this kind
of framing leads us to new questions
that we can still build theories around
um is that valuable then and that's
something that we can necessarily judge
right because it's something that's we
don't even know yet and so right it's
really hard to evaluate these Frameworks
when
um you don't know what they could lead
to right so okay so there's
um
there there is in science there there is
a a toppling and a replacement of
theories but also yeah you're right
there's you can have you can have
multiple theories at once obviously so
multiple research programs
uh
do you know do you know locatosh the
philosopher of science
I think so yeah well he talks about
research programs so he
he
he talks about multiple competing
research programs will exist
and those research programs are based on
a theory and that theory itself is never
questioned by the research program it's
based it's it's founded on it so the the
foundational theory of the research
program is considered to be true
and then you just use that that theory
to generate hypotheses and test those
hypotheses and he has the way he he
picture science is that you've got a
bunch of these going at once
different scientists are working on
different uh different theories and
those are those are in competition with
each other but but Loosely you're if
your theory is consistently leading to
new discoveries then it's a good theory
it doesn't mean it's true it just means
it's a good theory that the research
program is I think he calls it a
progressive research program and
basically he said you know if you have a
progressive research program
most likely you're going to be
consistently attracting funding and
consistently attracting new researchers
and you could have a bunch of these
very different research programs
studying the same topic and they might
all be equally Progressive for a while
but eventually one will you know in most
cases one will eventually end up
attracting the majority of people
because it's it's working more
efficiently and it will end up it will
end up overcoming over overwhelming the
other research programs so he it's kind
of like the
it's in contrast to like the coonian
revolutions where there's um yeah so I
suppose he's kind of more of a pluralist
uh like like what you're saying and the
other thing that I'm hearing from what
you're saying is that there's kind of uh
there's different ways to frame the same
problem
I've I've noticed this in the theory of
evolution there's um
like there's like the kin selection
models which are using
kind of like the the classical
um
the classical mathematics and then there
are there are there's the new group
section stuff
which uh I've I've heard from I've
talked to uh at length with Stuart West
about this who's that over at Oxford
and he describes what he's saying is is
that there's
because he argued against the group
selection stuff for a long time
and what he's saying is that uh
the group selection people right now
they're actually not wrong they're
they're looking at things from a very
different perspective but their math
works out he finds their math he finds
that the the way that they're doing
things is complicated and kind of it's
like the long route for doing for
solving most problems but he he says
that at this point they've actually
solved a lot of the problems that he had
issues with earlier on they've solved
those and they've found basically just a
different way to to a completely
different way to think about the same
thing yeah and they're basically coming
to the same conclusions so
there it's
it's like there's there's several ways
to do a long division right and you get
the same answer and exploring different
routes is valuable I think
so I don't I don't see a problem with
with uh
yeah this pluralistic way of doing
things one problem I do see though is
that scientists will talk past each
other scientists will think that they
have
that they they are the ones that that
figured out the true way of thinking
about this they'll pretend that they've
they've uh
they've triggered a coonian revolution
oh yeah and that they now have the
capital T truth on on and and it it gets
really childish it's like from the
outside looking at it's it's kind of
funny to watch but I mean okay so
there's a lot of things here yeah and
one other thing is more of the kind of
like the materialist aspect of it
because you know everyone's still trying
to
you know secure a job or like find more
fellowship and so this is it's important
to kind of Stand By Your Own
um ideas I guess but I feel like there's
also kind of a
maybe a historical Legacy effect of like
Carl poppers falsifiability you know
like Occam's razor for example and I
feel like these these um these ideas
aren't actually
um
they don't explicitly claim this but I
feel like it gets the false impression
impression to people that there is like
one true thing even though we don't get
there but we'll like slowly get in there
um or like you know yeah basically just
this one thing
um but this is yeah this is these
falsifiability and Occam's razor are
themselves
um philosophical stands like these these
things these Concepts aren't falsifiable
themselves and so like when you when you
use these as claims for like
your theory is better or something like
it's not grounded on
any form of like
um
ability to explain more or whatever yeah
yeah I I think that's one reason that I
really liked lochatosh as a philosopher
unfortunately he died like
halfway through really putting together
his thoughts but uh he in fact a lot of
us a lot of his best stuff was published
after he died
but he he was very much
yeah he did not believe he seemed not to
believe that you come to these solid
conclusions he was very much like if
it's working keep doing it if it's not
working then stop so I guess just
yeah
if it's leading to new discoveries it is
good
um
and I really like that that way of
thinking about science instead of
instead of trying to say that this is
the true way I like during covet it was
the worst of it because we had
there's very little data on everything
so all the things that we were doing
um
you know we had we have the
the public health
groups are trying to come up with
solutions for like how do we deal with
covid and they kept on using science as
this like
um we have the science and so this is
true this is what we should be doing
and it was like
I've seen the data that you're basing
all these conclusions on
it's not very good data it's the best
that we have I appreciate what you're
trying to do here
but people kept overstating our
certainty on you know the the usefulness
of mass the use the the effectiveness of
vaccines the like everything was
overstated
and like people can tell like when you
when you're over promising an under
delivering consistently people notice
and it it ended up being like everything
was oversold to the point that
it caused it caused people to Rebel
and have good good reason to
to not trust what they're being told
just just that if we had just spent more
transparent like hey we don't know fully
what's going on here
but we think that this vaccine is the
best way to go
you know it was just um
it was
man it was it was almost like
yeah it was very an emotional time for
me seeing uh
the people just misuse science in my
opinion yeah
the reputation of science
this is so difficult though because
I feel like
no I don't know how this might turn out
but if scientists or you know
um politicians uh paint the picture that
science is the most
robust the way of doing things if they
um if they pick if they communicate it
as if there is some kind of uncertainty
will people take it as like oh no they
don't know what they're doing
um
or like what like basically am I saying
like being transparent of your
uncertainty does that make them more
trustworthy or less trustworthy
yeah I mean it's a good question for me
it makes it way more trustworthy all
right but you know I mean one of the
things that you know growing up
religious I I had this too is that
we are like behind the pulpit there's
100 certainty of everything like your
your pastor knows exactly what's
happening or they pretend to
and so that's why people are being sold
at church and if people are being sold
uncertainty from government agencies or
from scientists then they uh they
interpret that as weakness which is just
uh their own ignorance I mean what what
they're hearing from behind the pulpit
is you know it is ABS the person's just
pretending so the
it's a hard problem
like how do you when you're trying to
deliver information to the masses how do
you do it in a way that's actually going
to hit but I just feel like
I feel like pretending that we have more
certainty than we actually do is not the
way to go I feel like I feel like
transparency is the way I'm I mean it
it's how I
it I mean it's the guiding principle in
my work
and I do get a lot of people um who uh
you know I I have a video what is the
evidence Revolution and people like and
I get a lot of comments like oh the
evidence suggests huh oh
um these are the conclusions oh well
that you don't know anything and I get I
get those types of comments all the time
but it's like yeah that's that's how
reality works we actually don't we
actually don't know what the heck we are
there's a lot of uncertainty
um yeah and I it's really easy to like
just label God right anything we don't
know God yeah fixes everything yeah yeah
yeah and so even like
you know I'd I would consider most
people consider me either an agnostic or
an atheist uh because where I'm at with
with religion is that as far as I can
tell
all the gods that people believe in are
cultural inventions
but so far as I can tell it's not like a
I don't know because you know I
I don't understand everything about the
cosmos but
that's where I stand tentatively uh at
this point in my life and uh so some
people would consider that to be an
atheist some people consider to be
agnostic but it's um I I yeah I feel
like the
the healthy the healthy way to think
about reality is that
obviously we're very limited in our
understanding we don't know what's
happening we don't we don't know what's
going on we only know what we
what's right in front of us
um yeah and I I feel like so as as far
as like public health officials
I feel like I feel like the best thing
for them to do would be to
especially at this point in history is
to be more transparent because
I think maybe
in in the past
you could have an authority figure just
tell people how things are and no one
would be able to check them on it but
now we have the internet and we have
there's a lot of smart people that are
questioning things and you can't you
can't really
I I don't think that our government
officials like Health officials can get
away with just uh
saying what they want like we have to be
we have to find a new way to deal with
things like
I think transparency is the way forward
like that it always should have been and
I think I think the internet is going to
force us to be transparent
um moving forward so
uh this is kind of related to what I was
saying about like consensus building and
that science is kind of like a social
activity
um like basically once you have your
information out there then people can
kind of you know in a Senate vote on it
right and then the ones that kind of do
kind of
receive the most support kind of becomes
at least the best theory at the present
time
yeah
yeah well so I I hear a lot of people
complain about scientific consensus like
that's a that's a really bad way to come
to a conclusion is through consensus
because it's you know conclusion by
voting
um
like so right now I don't know how much
we want to go into this but uh like the
origin of covid is
we don't have enough data to say
anything solid as to exactly how covet
originated there's these
I mean early on
nowadays whenever a new virus comes out
that like the
the
government the U.S government considers
three possibilities they consider it to
be engineered as a weapon they consider
it to be a lab accident and they
consider it to be a natural origin which
is the most likely for anything is the
natural origin
uh We've pretty solidly ruled out that
this is a weapon
but still there's there are these two
hypotheses on the table this was a lab
accident or that this was a natural
origin
and people are not uh
like
we don't have enough data to say for
sure one way or the other but people are
just um
they're fighting about it as if we do
have enough data I don't know I don't
know if you've been following that
argument much I've been following that
much yeah
well let's
let's talk about your research a little
bit more I I had you published an
article on um
what's it called bios squared
bios two yeah yeah bios two okay
yeah
um and that was oh man I didn't write
down the title of that article it was do
you remember what it was
Computing biology or biology Computing
yeah yeah Computing yeah
I'll put a link to that in the video
description for people to to read
afterwards I really liked it one of the
one of the things that you said in the
article you said evolution by natural
selection
a process unique to life is itself an
optimization algorithm and so you're
thinking about this you're thinking
about biology as computation and yeah I
really like that
uh so I don't wanna I don't want to make
the argument that it is
um it's more of just like a framework
that I see it as and I find it useful
for yeah I think that's an important
distinction to make that like yeah
people take their framework as the thing
itself but it's really just some kind of
representation
well tell us what you mean by that tell
us tell us what it is for you to think
about biology as computation
um I mean this is actually kind of a
yeah I guess like
I might so the something that got me
into computation is the fact that I
actually am horrible at math yeah oh me
too and then yeah and then I guess like
towards the end of my undergrad and
learned a little bit of coding and like
stat Jackson
and then like some for some reason like
it kind of
stick to me
um and I could understand the math a bit
more and the things come in discrete
chunks and then how when I you know
write a function I have to actually code
it up and it feels like for me it's like
super tangible and I can see how the
how the bits come together to form this
function or whatever yeah um and that's
just became super intuitive to me
and then
um and then I realized like oh this is
like super super meta in the sense that
like you know when every time I'm making
decisions I'm like waking up and like
going you know taking the bus and like
there's so there's like it's very
procedural and then if you like do a lot
of coding you realize oh it's kind of
like similar to like how programs work
when you follow these steps and this is
what you're doing
um and so I for me that I had a
um I guess like
gravitate towards this more computation
of you and I found it super intuitive
and I also recognized that this is also
very lifelike
um that life has this capacity to
process information and make decisions
on these based on these information that
they
um receive and process
and so
for me that was like a super like
natural way into
like this notion of computational
biology but like really enough
um yeah so this my article was a little
bit making the distinction between these
two different approaches yeah one is
um so like I think traditional
computational biologists you're thinking
like bioinformatics and people like
running a lot of scripts to like analyze
you know genomes and stuff like that and
like you know doing some machine
learning algorithms to find like data
and stuff like that
um but I'm kind of more interested in
okay wait how does that organism do that
all right how did it how are they doing
statistics I don't want to do statistics
on them I want I want to know how they
do statistics
um and yeah I feel like that's opened a
lot of happening in terms of research
questions and how to think about things
yeah there's a really neat video I think
probably the first time that I started
thinking about uh organisms as computers
you know as doing calculations I mean
obviously like if if I'm playing
basketball right I'm doing calculations
but I'm not doing them in a mathematical
way like not you know if I'm throwing a
basket ball into a into a hoop I'm
making a calculation
and I felt my way into those
calculations so it's through trial and
error right but the there's a really
neat video I watched it was David
Attenborough video on plants and it's it
was a video about the Venus flytrap and
if it's got these hairs inside the fly
trap and if a fly hits those hairs three
times within a certain time frame it'll
snap shut because it's you know that's
how the uh it's evolved to be like okay
if something hits once maybe something
just fell on me if something hits twice
maybe something's moving in the wind but
three times
most likely there's there's food there
but
the it's just it's so interesting to
think about this because I'm thinking
like what is happening here well these
these hairs are triggered and it's
causing some sort of chemical probably
too span out through the tissue of this
organism and then if that happens again
more of that chemical and it's like
there must be like
a level where when there's enough of
that chemical then the thing snaps shut
and so there's some sort of uh
an overflow that's set inside the
organism it's set in advance inside the
organism that oh when there's this much
of this chemical flowing through my body
I snap shut
and it's
I mean it's basically there's basically
logic gates yes yeah yeah exactly and
the other really beautiful thing is is
I've been studying uh this was a while
ago I was looking into this is how it is
that that new blood vessels are summoned
so when there's a bit of tissue that's
oxygen starved it'll send out a molecule
that's it's actually a
part of the metabolism when it's when a
cell is not getting enough oxygen it
starts screwing up it messes up its
metabolism
and it starts secreting these molecules
that are an honest signal that it's it's
struggling
and there is
there there are cells in the our blood
vessels they can that that receive that
that molecule and they start growing
towards it and so they're using it's
it's the same thing that if you see an
amoeba that's that smells something and
is going towards it to eat it it's the
same exact same mechanism I mean you
have this this cell that it's basically
it smells that and it's going towards it
I mean it smells it it's it's got
receptors it's grabbing those molecules
and digesting them and then moving
towards them and it's just moving to
where they're stronger and stronger and
stronger and you've got all of these all
these blood vessels growing towards it
at the same time when one of them gets
there first then the scent goes away
because it's it's giving oxygen to this
cell these this this bit of tissue so it
stops sending the signal so the other
vessels stop growing so you get this
like perfect
uh
growth of blood vessels as needed when
needed and you don't need any you don't
need any map it's just all exactly it's
so cool how it works and that is exactly
yeah it's it's a type of computation
that's uh that's a very analog type of
comp of computation that's happening uh
self-organizing yeah yeah I love that
it's just so cool uh yeah
but yeah you could say everything from
when we wake up in the morning
we have two desires one desire to stay
in bed one desire to get up and do our
thing and there's
there's
a calculation based on
chemistry like how much of a drive is
there for me to get up and start my day
how much of a drive is there for me to
stay in bed and it's just a calculation
that's happening right
um
I will say that like ah
um I feel like everything you you said
is right and definitely true but there's
also a more active so I think everything
you've been saying is very kind of
passive and reactive
um maybe you're getting examples of
chemicals and like
um basically reducing it to kind of like
the biochemistry
um but this is something I've been like
I think this is
well
in the literature I'm pretty sure it's
like well-founded the idea that
some
um computational entities have the
capacity to
forecast or anticipate and so they're
basically anticipating things that don't
even exist yet or they don't haven't
they haven't sensed yet
um and so I think this is this is kind
of why I feel like this agential view is
kind of important and actually it might
be ontologically relevant in this sense
that
um certain organizations
um
give
The Entity the capacity to build some
sort of mental model
and forecast things that they haven't
seen yet and because this is a forecast
it's not they're not reacting to
something they're basically trying to do
something that they think might happen
um and so this is what this yeah this
becomes kind of like
um
active and more agential I guess
yeah so obviously we're familiar with us
ourselves doing this because we're
always forecasting we think about the
future probably
as much as we think about the past and
the present mm-hmm so we're constantly
trying to do that
um
how far back do you see this happening
or far back how how simple of an
organism do you see that's that's doing
this it's actually trying to make novel
predictions about the future
uh
uh I guess by I guess by what by by
mixing
by mixing observations of the past into
new
uh
it's I mean it's kind of uh founded upon
the notion of counter factual reasoning
Yeah so basically ability to like what
if ask the question of what if
um and I I'm not this is something I'm
still like figuring out myself it's like
whether or not this this capacity isn't
necessarily requires some kind of
cognitive architecture
um and like you know if you if you look
into computational and like kind of
information Theory perspective then like
you don't like
like I kind of wrote that in the paper
in the in the blog as well it's like
matter doesn't matter as long as you as
you have those organizations
um
then it can have the capacity to
form or make anticipations so you're
saying that a nervous system doesn't
matter
um as long as you have a a network of
some sort that's set up in the right way
it could it can it can have a mind
yeah exactly so like I mean the thing is
kind of like
going to colonies for example like slime
molds yeah like and colonies where those
individuals actually don't do anything
but collectively they're kind of
processing information exchanging
information and that somehow gives them
some kind of higher level functionality
that you can't
just reduce to the parts
yeah
yeah
um I I want to talk about a little bit
more a bit here but let's
just for viewers who are still watching
if you have any specific questions
for William just type those down in the
comments it seems like I wasn't really
watching comments but it seemed like
there's a little bit of a an argument
going on in there about uh
looks like it has some sort of a like
religion argument going on in there uh
if you guys have specific questions
about Williams research about his
scientific thinking or about like
fundamentally what is science and how is
it different from other things that we
do let us know in the comments but
um
yeah let's talk a little bit more about
this so the uh
that last thought the the the
I I've heard a lot of people complain
about reductionism right yeah uh
and I don't I don't understand the
frustration with it for me it seems like
in order to understand a system
you have to understand its parts
uh and how they come together to make
the larger system and for me that's what
reductionism is it's just like okay we
see a system we can study that system in
and of itself but also we can pick it
apart and study the sub systems of that
system and we can keep doing that until
we hit
this Foundation where we're too dumb to
look further because we just don't know
how to look deeper and to me that seems
like
that's what reductionism is and how
could that possibly be bad but I see a
bunch of people complain about
reductionism that it's we oversimplify
things
um
so
I don't know if that if that's totally
different from what you were just saying
you were saying that the uh
yeah a little bit
um I mean
sometimes
sometimes it's useful to sometimes it's
not necessarily uh helpful to look down
into the parts yeah
that Parts might not have whatever thing
you're trying to explain
right
um and so like I mean the greatest
the example that a lot of people often
give is you know carbon atoms right
um You have these carbon atoms and then
somehow you can form graphene or like
higher level crystalline structures that
like give the property of them the
property of the material but like
there's nothing about the carbon atom
that tells you it can do that right you
have to still just put them in that way
um
and like
yeah and so
and and I think there's I think this is
another I mean another aspect of it is
that it kind of promotes Doug mattis's
dogmaticism which is that you know we
can just reduce everything to physics
um and like and then the issue the
problem right now with especially with
like theoretical physics is that
you go into these like
super theoretical physics and then
everything just becomes like even
shadier and then so like our our we
thought that going down might help
become there's more certainty and then
all of a sudden we speak quantum
mechanics and everything just breaks
down it's like okay so at the bottom of
this we still don't have certainty so
like
so how does reduction and reductionism
work if like we go the very bottom level
we even we see even more like randomness
um okay well well but here's my argument
though so we talked about carbon for
example like yeah
it's playing with little carbon models
that we can figure out all the different
ways that you can set up a carbon
structure right yeah
um
and then it's understanding how carbon
Works in real life
and the types of reactions that can get
you to build the lattice versus uh you
know I mean like it really is
understanding carbon that helps us
understand all the different things you
can build with carbon uh
so I I don't understand how I don't
understand how understanding the pieces
doesn't help us there oh I mean I'm not
uh I'm I'm not denying reductionism but
the fact that
that's not always helpful in
understanding the thing we're explaining
yeah
um so I mean so I always
think of this myself and I find myself I
don't know if you're familiar with like
cellular automatives for example yes
yeah yeah
and so you you know how there's like
Elementary rules
um you know if your neighbor if is um
I mean depending on how many neighbors
you have you kind of like
you used to reproduce right yeah yeah
exactly
um and so these different different
rules per um produce different
structures right yeah
um and so for example The Game of Life
right there's certain certain Rule and
then you can generate Game of Life
um and then
the the interesting thing is that let's
say you analyze all these rules
um without running it can you know which
one will generate The Game of Life
yeah I don't I don't think there's any
way to figure it like the only the only
way we can figure out the game of life
is to run it yeah yeah exactly and so
like there's nothing in that Elementary
rule that tells you what it will give
rise to well um no one's figured out how
to predict it right
from from first principles so so what
what you're saying is that from first
principles you cannot figure out the you
cannot go from first principles to
of
of any system too like
what's possible what can possibly emerge
from it yeah you can't predict but just
based on the rules what's going to
happen yeah right yeah I think this is
proven though just based on like
I think well there's a thousand
companies theorem it's like that well
there's a prize that are undecidable
yeah there's a prize right now to try to
find a way to make predictions with
cellular automata and I think the
purpose of the prize is is just kind of
a middle finger like you can't do it
it's not possible yeah exactly I think
that's what the point is yeah but yeah
exactly but yeah it so I agree with you
that we can't
um
to predict what can emerge from first
principles is
very difficult and and I think I think
you're right that it's impossible in
many ways but to understand what's
already happening by understanding the
pieces
um
that are coming together to make it I
think that's super helpful like if I
want to understand how a Bicycle Works
it understanding yeah understanding how
the gears all work is is really
important I I feel like there's a like
in this in this debate that I keep
seeing pop up mostly on Twitter where it
reductionism is bad basically yeah it's
like well
I I kind of feel like the the
the
anti-reductionists are making a cartoon
of of what what we're doing I mean we're
trying to we're trying to break things
apart
to figure out how the pieces work and
how they work together to generate the
uh the emergent property uh
sorry go ahead I just want to say like I
feel like especially people without
working on origin of life this is a
particular relevant question yeah um
it's because and and that might be a
reason why reductionism kind of fails
because it's like I don't know if you're
familiar with like let's do a Kaufman or
Robert Rosen or like um Francisco Varela
they have this notion of organizational
closure
um where the parts don't even exist
without the hole right and so like you
can't even separate them because once
you separate them those those parts
don't exist anymore
um and so you can think about for
example like this citric acid cycle yeah
you have these different components
um but if you like split one up the
whole thing just like disappears right
and so like
it's really hard to just like isolate
them because that's that's taken the
context out of it right and so once you
take the context out then that's not
that's not even relevant anymore
um
yeah I mean so there's like Arguments
for from for that reason and also
arguments why like
biology or living organisms aren't
machines
um because they're not like mechanizable
in that sense
um
okay yeah that that is a that's an
argument that I that I don't fully
understand like the
um
it does seem to me that that uh well
like the citric acid cycle for example
um we've built we've built
um
chains so we have a lot of different
partial versions of the citric acid
cycle that we can all find
um and as long as you have something
that's feeding it it can keep on it can
keep working it's just that it if unless
it's until it's a full cycle it's not
self-sustaining but yeah exactly you can
feed it you can you can feed a linear
um
reaction and it'll keep going forever
but the
so so yeah we can reduce those things we
can reduce them in lots of different
ways and they still work they just don't
work the way that it's working now so I
I yeah yeah
um
hey I I do feel like breaking these
things apart is how
breaking them apart seeing how they work
in different ways is super helpful we
got a couple questions here from the
audience here okay George says how do
you think Consciousness factors into the
material view of science there are many
research programs attempting to
synthesize uh phenomenology conscious
thought with the
Psych psychology or neurobiology
um
your thoughts on that it's a lot to take
in
um wait so sorry what was the question
like what is consciousness what how does
it fit into how does it fit into
materials yeah
damn
um
that's like the Crux of the problem
right
I mean like if you take that
Consciousness is the material emergent
phenomena of material processes then
then yeah I guess like finding your core
that's sort of like kind of
understanding how neurons work is
basically the solution
um but if you have a stance that
Consciousness is more of a immaterial
thing it has its own existence
beyond the material world then
um yeah I don't know how to tackle
tackle I I do know some people are like
trying to do some experiments with that
for example like
um with like meditation for example yeah
there's some scriptures that like
Consciousness its own basically you can
think about these two worlds and then
like they're kind of
and materializes and
um I think about it as like a stream of
like or like a radio channel and then
material I think the material was
somehow like just tuned into that like
Consciousness and that's why I like
Consciousness somehow projected into the
material world that that's how you think
of the Duelist picture of consciousness
yeah yeah
um and so I think some people are
proposing
um experiments with like meditation for
example so the idea of meditation is
that somehow when you just like go
absolutely into this like deep
meditative
um State you can actually
kind of be in that like pure
Consciousness
um State and the idea is that you know
if since we all are channeled in on this
like one Consciousness
um source and the idea is that like
different people
might be able to see
um the histories and memories from that
Consciousness and so maybe me and you we
have different lives right but then for
some reason if we're doing a meditative
Zone we start seeing the same thing and
so that might be uh
uh a sign or um
that that you know we do we are shared
by dislike single Consciousness thing
um well it will be some kind of evidence
for it yeah it's a it's a really hard
thing to study because I think
so you know just just thinking about the
with the history of Western science we
have this really solid um
love for observations mainly visual
observations is that it's the main type
of observation that Science is based on
um yeah and it's really hard to turn it
like an experience that someone has
while meditating
into something that everybody else can
study uh yeah so I know that people are
trying to get better and better at brain
scans and so on because that's one way
that we could you know we can turn in
these like personal experiences into
everyone has access to observe this
personal experience because we have
brain scans and we can trust we can
trust these brand scans better than
someone's testimony because again the
slogan of science is nullius and verba
take no one's word
and you literally have to take someone's
word to study their conscious experience
right right now yes so these brain scans
are kind of helping us so that we don't
have to take their word but it's
difficult like
so the yeah the idea that
that I would say that the two main ideas
about Consciousness one idea is that it
emerges from our nervous system
the other idea or somehow of the the
body in the material body the other idea
is that it's a separate thing and that
we are receiving it
um we know that we're either generating
or we're receiving it because if you
injure the brain it ruins the person's
ability to be conscious right
so obviously that's what we think at
least obviously the material seems to uh
the material of the brain seems to be
important for this right like if you cut
out a piece of someone's brain they can
no longer
uh talk to you about what they're
they're experiencing
so the obviously the material is
important here right
and somewhere
but whether or not Consciousness is
generated by the brain or it's tapped
into by the brain I suppose that that's
something that we haven't
no one's been able to figure out right
yeah but obviously I'm I'm no expert so
yeah so yeah I I guess George to answer
answer your question uh that's that's
one of the big things we don't
understand is what Consciousness is why
is it why does it feel like something to
be alive
you know versus my computer I assume
that my computer does not feel anything
but it's also doing all sorts of
computation why does a computation eye
do you feel like something
and maybe you know there are there are
also people who say that actually maybe
your computer feels stuff too or maybe
matter itself feels something to yeah so
that's like pan psychism yeah right yeah
yeah and these are just unknowns like we
don't know it's uh yeah
that's the only question yeah I mean
it's funny yeah okay
so far sorry say what you're gonna say I
know I'm just going to say like I yeah I
mean like the argument is like whether
or not this is even
a good question yeah
um that itself is kind of an open
question right
but it's so funny because like
it's almost to us individually
like the subjective experience is
literally all we know right and somehow
that's the thing that we can't know
yeah yeah well I I describe it like this
like
expecting that we can understand
Consciousness is kind of like expecting
that a dog could swallow itself like the
last bite is really difficult you know
yeah and uh like could a human mind
understand
what it is to be a mind like I don't I
don't know that it's even possible to
fully comprehend
consciousness
uh so maybe the only way we'll figure
this out is we'll build the computer
that's smarter than us and it can figure
out how we work but it can't figure out
how it works and uh so on it's just uh
yeah you know
um
unexplained Consciousness all the way up
it's Turtles all the way down
unexplained Consciousness all the way up
so yeah I don't know yeah well uh we're
at we're at about an hour and a half now
they're getting close there
uh yeah I feel like I feel like this is
fun like teasing apart what is science
um
anything anything you want to say before
we part ways here so your argument is
that we should think about
organisms as having having agency is
that
is that what you think having agency or
calling them agents is there a
difference too okay I have an agency and
and I I guess we could have teased that
apart a little bit more here what
exactly do you mean by agency
so um I think this comes down to like
those reduction as an idea which is we
try to take a take part things that
we take it apart
um
by by taking things apart we removed the
organism right and so like it's like
the organism itself is never a causal
causal agent like it never has a causal
role in its own persistence because it's
just the genes or it's just an
environment
um but I think the organism is more of
like the kind of interaction between
these two things and through these
interactions it actually has some form
of autonomy
um where there's like a self and there's
like an environment
um an ability to process information
kind of like makes it
gives it the capacity to like make
decisions to navigate and like
um so I I while ago I said like
evolution is an optimization problem and
some people don't like that because it's
kind of like
adaptioness and it kind of input implies
some idea that there's a problem for
things to solve but I'm okay with that
because I think that problem is
subjective like the agent because have
it has some sort of autonomy it can form
the problem that it wants to solve yeah
um so I don't think necessarily has to
be imposed by the environment
but yeah basically I think organisms
should be studied or it should be
um should be as real of a thing than
whatever Parts is made out of
and okay yeah that's kind of what gives
it autonomy in an agency
yeah
yeah I I'm trying to I'm trying to
simplify this like
so
to get away from Consciousness or the
concept of agency because these are
things again there's a lot of baggage
behind both of these words here but like
if I just think about teeth like yeah
The evolutionary invention of teeth
was a huge Innovation it allows it
allows me to process energy that was
previously
could not be processed because I can now
smash things which you know if you look
at a if you look at bacteria for example
or single-celled organisms they're doing
everything with chemical reactions
they're trying to digest things and
break things apart all at the molecular
level
once you get teeth you can now just
smash stuff which is awesome and then
you can have all the chemical reactions
afterwards that that do the further
breaking down
uh yeah but the emergence of teeth like
that's it's a bunch of cells working
together to create these teeth
and those teeth then smash stuff and
it's a bunch of cells working together
to let those teeth smash things
um
and yeah you have to study the teeth at
the at the level of teeth you can't you
can't just study that only at the level
of genes or else it doesn't make sense
but I I don't feel like
I don't feel like there's ever been
confusion about that like of course we
have to study this system
at its it's not just a teeth though the
macro level like how it's used with you
need something to smash as well yeah
yeah yeah you're right you're right it's
not asking why is it smashing but but I
feel like we already studied we already
study everything so we study things at
the the
biome level we study things at the
ecology level we study things at the
individual level we study things at the
cellular level like I feel like there's
already this
multi-level view of studying biology so
I I guess what
it I I don't understand the complaint
like when people say that reductionism
is is
um we're ignoring the organism I don't
understand where that comes from because
there's tons of literature about
organisms and their behavior or their
their organs and how those organs
function and how how an ecosystem
functions and so on yeah
um are you do you see do you feel like
there's actually a lack of no I totally
agree with you on that I'm I'm
personally still also figuring out
whether or not it's like ontologically
worth
um
labeling an emergent thing that that's
like has its own you know fundamental
existence
um but another thing is more of like I
think for me at least it's like more of
a political thing yeah
um where like for example I feel like
reductionism somehow implies some sort
of determinism and it becomes really
really
um political but also a little bit like
social in the sense that like you know I
look at you and I can say like because
you're this so I can know who you are
and yeah I can basically explain you
based on the parts that you have
um right but like I feel like life is
I really think that life and non-life is
kind of the capacity to to change and
morph into things that you can't even
um predict or anticipate
um
so yeah and so I feel like that's kind
of the concept of emergence where
yeah the thing becomes something more
than just whatever the parts are
so maybe maybe you feel like we're too
confident in what can be concluded
um yeah yeah based on current knowledge
yeah yeah I would agree with that
um
yeah interesting
I'm trying to see if there's any more
questions from people before we close
here
yeah hey
looks like that's it well any any final
words before we part ways here
um
well I guess yeah I'm this has turned
out better than I thought it would be
honestly didn't know what to expect and
um thank you for the invitation and it
was pretty good chat with you yeah it's
fun to just go wherever it goes yeah
yeah uh I'm gonna I'm gonna put a link
in the video description here in a
couple of minutes to uh Williams article
and it's yeah it's pretty cool it's it's
fun to think about uh even the process
of evolution itself as an algorithm it's
really it's really interesting to think
about it that way uh
yeah thanks for coming on and
yeah good luck on future endeavors
you're about to travel for the holidays
safe travels
and uh yeah I'll talk to you later
see ya thanks so long